that graphic is good big brother mailman
but it's real it turns out postal
service not just delivering the mail
also spying on you
true story fox's trace gallagher has the
details for us today hey trace
and tucker legal experts are baffled for
two reasons one because by surveilling
american social media accounts the u.s
postal service is monitoring lawfully
protected speech
which of course raises constitutional
concerns and
two if big brother mailman is looking
for criminal activity
that would normally be the fbi's job
right and yet according to a memo
obtained by yahoo news the u.s postal
inspection service which by the way is
the law enforcement arm
of the usps is running what it calls the
internet covert operations program or
icop and the primary objective appears
to be collecting data
about planned protests in the document
obtained by yahoo big brother mailman
was looking for
inflammatory posts about the worldwide
rally for freedom
held back in march that's where
thousands of people around the world
protested coveted lockdowns but instead
of looking for potential nefarious
behavior across the board
the main surveillance was of facebook
and
quote right wing leaning parlor and
telegram and the memo did mention the
right-wing proud boys
and said without citing intelligence
that some people on parlor
intended to quote do serious damage but
there was no mention of
any left-wing groups like antifa
surprising considering
the lion's share of the protest violence
over the past year
has been caused by left-wing groups
incidentally the worldwide freedom rally
did spark violence in some countries but
none
that we could find in this country
tucker
tells you a lot trace gallagher thanks
so much sure